let me ask you I mean there's a million
ways to ask this question I'm sure I'll
ask it about habitable worlds
let's just go to our own solar system
what can we learn about the planets and
moons
in our solar system that
might contain life whether it's Mars or
some of the moons of Jupiter and Saturn
what kind of characteristics because you
said it might not need to be Earth-like
what kind of characteristics might be
we'd be looking for
when we look for life it's hard to
Define even what life is
um but we can maybe do a better job in
defining the sorts of things that life
does and that provides
um some aspects to some Avenue for
looking for them
um any classically conventionally I
think we thought the way to look for
life was to look for oxygen oxygen is a
byproduct of fetch synthesis on this
planet we didn't always have it
certainly if you go back to the Arcane
period
um there was you know you have this
period called the Great oxidation event
where the Earth floods with oxygen for
the first time and starts to saturate
the oceans and then the atmosphere and
so that oxygen if we detect it on
another planet whether it be Mars Venus
or an exoplank whatever it is
um that was long thought to be evidence
for something doing photosynthesis
because if you took away all the plant
life on the earth the oxygen wouldn't
just hang around here it's a highly
reactive molecule it would oxidize
things and So within about a million
years you would probably lose all the
oxygen on planet Earth
so that was a conventionally how we
thought we could look for life and then
we start to realize that it's not so
simple because either might be other
things that life does apart from
photosynthesis certainly the vast
majority of the Earth's history had no
oxygen and yet there was living things
on it so that doesn't seem like a
complete test
and secondly could there be other things
that produce oxygen besides from Life
um a growing concern has been these
false positives in biosignature work and
so one example of that would be
photolysis that happens in the
atmosphere when ultraviolet right hits
the upper atmosphere can break up water
vapor the hydrogen splits off to the
oxygen the hydrogen is much lighter
Atomic species and so it can actually
Escape certainly plants like the Earth's
gravity that's why we don't have any
hydrogen or very little helium and so
that leaves you with the oxygen which
then oxidizes the surface and so there
could be a residual oxygen signature
just due to this photolysis process
so we've been trying to generalize and
um certainly in recent years there's
been other suggestions things we could
look for in the solar system Beyond uh
nitrous oxide basically laughing gas is
a product of microbes
um that's something that we're starting
to get more interested in looking for
methane gas in combination with other
gases can be an important biosignature
phosphine as well and phosphine is
particularly relevant to the solar
system because there was a lot of
interest for Venus recently
um you may have heard that there was a
claim of a biosignature in Venus's
atmosphere I think it was like two years
ago now
and the the judge and jury is still out
on that
um there was a very provocative claim
and signature of a phosphine-like
spectral absorption
um but it could have also have been some
of the molecule in particular sulfur
dioxide
which is not a buyer signature so this
is a detection of a gas in the
atmosphere yeah Venus and and uh it
might be controversial on several
and dimensions so one had to interpret
that two is a thread gas and three is
this even the right detection is this is
there an error in the detection yeah I
mean how much do we believe that's
actually in the first place if you do
believe it does that necessarily mean
there's life there and um what gives how
can you have life in the Venus's
atmosphere in the first place because
that's you know been seen as like a hell
hole place for imagining life but I
guess the the counter that has been that
okay yes the surface is a horrendous
place to imagine life thriving
um but as you go up in altitude the very
dense atmosphere means that there is a
cloud layer
um where the temperature and the
pressure become actually fairly similar
to the surface of the Earth and so it
may be there are microbes stirring
around in the clouds which are producing
phosphine
um at the moment this is fascinating
it's got a lot of us
reinvigorated about the prospects of
going back to Venus and doing another
mission there in fact there's now two
NASA missions Veritas and DaVinci which
I can be going back and before 23rd to
the 2030s
um and then we have a European Mission I
think that's slated now and even a
Chinese Mission might be coming along
the way as well so we might have
multiple missions going to Venus which
has long been overlooked I mean apart
from the Soviets there really has been
very little in the way of exploration of
Venus that's certainly as compared to
Mars Mars has enjoyed most of the
activity from NASA's Rovers and surveys
and Mars is certainly fascinating
there's you know this signature of
methane that has been seen there before
um again there the discussion is whether
that methane is a product of biology
which is possible something that happens
on the earth or whether it's some
geological process that we are yet to
fully understand could be a for example
a reservoir of methane that's trapped
under the surface and it's leaking out
seasonally so the nice thing about Venus
is if there's a giant living
civilization there it'll be airborne so
you can just fly through and collect
samples yeah with Mars and uh moons of
uh Saturn Jupiter you're gonna have to
dig
under to find the civilizations right
dead or living right and so yeah maybe
it's easier than for Venus because
suddenly you can imagine just a balloon
floating through the atmosphere
um the or a drone or something that
would have the capability of just
scooping up and sampling